all right it gets crazier so uh look
there's this whole situation going down
in cuba the people of cuba want to be
free it really is as simple as that like
i don't need to give you
much more detail on the story than that
the people live under a communist regime
people don't have ownership they don't
have the ability to spend money freely
and actually
build generational wealth and make all
of the great successes that you can do
here in a capitalist country
and as i mentioned i was just in florida
and miami this past weekend there
are hundreds and thousands of if not
hundreds of thousands
of cuban immigrants there they love
america they are so proud of america
they are the reverse of
everything the mainstream tells you and
they are hard working
they're doing all the tough jobs so they
can build better lives for their
families and just listen to marco
rubio's personal story
okay or mayor suarez there or or a
litany of other people okay
so the cubans want to be free so our
administration is pretending that no
these
these uh rallies where they're literally
yelling
freedom they are yelling freedom and
liberty those are the buzzwords that
they're yelling
it's not really about freedom or liberty
from communism it's because they want
more coveted vaccinations that's what
these ridiculous
people in this clown administration that
we have
are doing well now department of
health secretary uh ali mayorkas
uh is got a warning for cuban refugees
he don't want him
let's take a look allow me to be clear
if you take to the sea you will not
come to the united states the time is
never right
to attempt migration by sea to those who
risk their lives
doing so this risk is not worth taking
again i repeat do not risk your life
attempting
to enter the united states illegally you
will not
come that's department of homeland
security by the way i think i might have
said health security there
but boy that does sound awfully racist
and mean i thought
i thought we're america where anyone can
come here at any time and if we don't
let you in that we're racist that's the
game we were playing under trump right
like you got to open up those borders
let anybody in don't really ask them
anything
give them all the services you know come
on america
it's horrible everyone join us you may
also remember
this lady tackling kamala just a few
weeks ago
talking about our border i want to be
clear to folks in this region who are
thinking about making
that dangerous trek to the united states
mexico border
do not come do not come
ah we should have played that video of
trump saying i'm going to come we should
have done that
we'll link that together after there's a
great meme of that where she's going
do not come do not come but trump goes
i'm going to come
do not come
do not come i'm going to come
[Applause]
[Music]
anyway she's a racist obviously by her
own words right because when trump was
saying don't come or you have to come
trump actually never told immigrants not
to come by the way if you listen to all
the videos of trump on this stuff
he would say we have to have a legal
process we have to have a border so we
know who's coming
and then we can have a legal process to
allow immigrants to come so
look by their own words our department
of homeland security and our vice
president
are racists and they obviously hate
cuban people now in a way they do hate
cuban people because
as i just said cubans come to america
and love the american dream
perhaps more than any other immigrant
group right like maybe not more than any
other immigrant group of all time
because we had plenty of immigrant
groups that have come
over decades and loved it but like as
first generations one
first generation immigrants in a modern
context in the context of 2021 i don't
know of a group that loves
america more there there might be from
maybe somewhere in africa that come
and work very hard and you know some
from mexico but like cubans come and
they love america and it's pretty
freaking spectacular
well now let's show you some video of
bernie sanders
and aoc and nancy pelosi talking about
trump's immigration policy and i think
you'll see that it was
a little bit different from these types
of people when
orange man was in charge we will rescind
all
of trump's hateful and racist
ex immigration executive orders
he has a proven track record of
discrimination
against anybody who's really non-white
in the united states
president first assumed office with his
with his uh
racist and violent rhetoric it's about
keeping
you know make america you know his hat
make
america white again they want to make
sure
that people certain people are counted
you know there's a line that i quote
every now and again from my friend
dennis prager and what he's been saying
for years is that the difference between
the left and the right
is that the right thinks that the left
is wrong and the left
think that thinks that the right is evil
and
i think that was the right estimation
for a long time but i'm actually
starting to think that these people are
evil
at what point if you lie about
everything
all the time if you lie about what
someone else is doing while you're doing
that very same thing
especially as a public person right as
people in charge of policy in the
direction of the country
at what point is this just blatantly
evil so unless
bernie sanders now wants to say that the
biden administration
is full of hatred and racist as he just
said
there about donald trump or aoc said
that
trump's policies are discriminatory and
they're racist and violent
and then of course nancy pelosi
basically implied that trump supporters
are all white supremacists well they
obviously
all should be completely against what
kamal is saying to
uh you know people in guatemala that's
what that video is from and from south
america coming here she's don't come
don't come okay so you're racist against
those people
and uh obviously the department of
homeland security
threatening these people who are under
the attack of a communist regime
obviously the department of homeland
security is racist and evil and
everything else now of course it's not
because
it's racist and evil it's because we
have a country and we have to figure out
how many people can be here
and we've also got some problems right
now and the economy was wrecked because
of the pandemic or whatever you want to
call it at this point and everything
else
so you see why this is all just nonsense
and they just
they just don't stop they just don't
stop so our work as i always say is cut
out for us
because if you're going to tell the
truth in a time of massive lies
it ain't going to be that easy but i
have nothing better to do
so we're going to just keep going